hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 25th 2019 what's going
on how why yeah I'm recording this in
New York City right before I get on a
plane that go fly to London do my little
run through the UK tape my special and
then come home and I ain't don't want
[ __ ] taping this Sunday or the 24th
tough day definitely a tough day they
have in this memorial for Steven Brody
Stevens tonight at the Comedy Store and
unfortunately I'm in New York and I
can't be there and crush that I can't be
there and say all the things I would
have liked to have said which really is
the strange thing about when somebody
dies do you ever notice when somebody
dies then you somehow immediately know
emotionally exactly what you wished you
of you would have said to the person
it's really weird but I kind of get it
because that's a heavy thing to do to
somebody like what would I say to this
person if I knew they were gonna die
tomorrow if you just [ __ ] hit them
with that while they're sitting there
eating a [ __ ] Cobb salad they're
gonna be looking at you like whoa dude
hey let's try to keep it light here okay
but I just that [ __ ] guy my god that
[ __ ] guy that guy made me laugh like
I don't know how to describe it the wind
and it was the weight like nobody ever
made me laugh that hard the way he made
me laugh it was completely 100% unique
unique unique sense of humor just really
you know what's funny is I've been I've
been talking all of these comics about
him over the last couple of days he and
we're all like quoting his jokes and
it's like if you don't know Brodie
it's it's kind of like you kind of have
to know him and you kinda have to be
familiar with his act on just because it
was his [ __ ] cadence half the time
like it's a good example I mean one time
I was down the Comedy Store we were in
the
main room and I was with my wife Nia and
Brody went on stage and I swear to god
that [ __ ] genius
went on stage and for ten minutes
described his dream apartment and no
there was no setups no punchlines
he was just describing in in like this
sort of I can't even it was like Zillow
speak meets like this amazing comedic
cadence I I don't even and I can't even
remember what he said me and you were
just looking at each other and we're
just dying laughing and I just it was
like you know ceiling to floor windows
stepping down into the living room and
when he said that my wife literally
almost fell out of her chair I know this
won't seem funny to a lot of you because
you didn't know him and I nobody can
recreate what that the way that that guy
did what he did but when he said
stepping down into the living room like
I just put my head down on the table and
was crying laughing at the same time
also for the first time ever in my life
noticing how much reverence that's the
right word that I held anybody like any
room that you stepped down in into in an
apartment is unbelievably classy and I
had no idea that I thought that and I
think the whole crowd along with me
suddenly realized in that most moment
that like we all felt that and had never
expressed it and Brody had just
expressed it and and he acted it out
stepping down and he sort of crouched
into the living room and it was just
amazing you know and it was and also to
like probably behind all of that on the
underneath was the sadness of of you
know like what he wanted and was he
going to get it and all of that type of
stuff that was just very relatable and I
don't know man it's like I have this
weird this is a weird one where I'm
really sad selfishly from myself but I'm
not like I don't know I'm not the most
spiritual guy but I just I feel like you
know
his journey was like complete I guess
you know that's how I have to look at it
or else it becomes too sad and when I
really look at how he affected everybody
and just the [ __ ] outpouring that was
on Twitter and how psyched he would have
been that you know that he that he was
trending on Twitter for two days now I
don't know it was just it was really
that that part of it was like a cool
thing to see and I I used to tried to
sit down and watch that show that he did
with Zach Galifianakis by the way shout
out to Zach for loaning his name to that
so Brody could do that show and it was
just too soon to sit there and watch it
and watch him struggle I just can't
imagine having a a mental illness
well you just literally just walking
around fighting your own brain and the
way that he was able to do that and not
lash out at other people and just be so
kind and so sweet to everybody and just
so [ __ ] funny man it's like it's
really it's it's an end of an era in at
The Comedy Store like this and there's
really not gonna be but there's not
there's no there was nobody
before after him that would that was
that was like that guy and furthermore
he truly in the purest sense was a was a
Comics comic where a lot of times that
gets thrown around oh this guy's a comic
comic or she's Comics comic and it's
somebody that's also selling a lot of
tickets it's almost like it means it's a
comedian that made it but other
comedians still like that person don't
resent their success is sort of the way
a Comics comic is sort of these I guess
definition of it or the way I kind of
see it but Brody was he was he was a
Comics comic in that he was really for
us like the waitstaff and people that
managed
some people who had watched that amount
of comedy to understand how unique he
was and how different he was and I love
going on the internet now and all these
people were just discovering him and
some people get no but there's a lot of
people being like this guy isn't funny
this guy sucks I'm sure you guys are sad
but this guy suck that makes me feel
even better it's like yeah you don't get
it you don't get it because you're not a
[ __ ] comedian and you just have like
you know where your comedic ear is is
take two guys walk into a bar and the
rabbi says like you're not gonna get
this [ __ ] guy like you have to watch
a lot of comedy to see how funny this
guy was and I'm really gonna miss him
and oh man I remember when I was doing I
was what was at the oddball the oddball
tour and I'd gone on the crowd was
[ __ ] you know was like I don't know
[ __ ] eight nine thousand people and
it was just such a rush to be on in
front and Brody was hosting and Chris
D'Elia was going on next and I've always
loved Chris like he just was like you
know he reminded me of like a Boston
comic where as far as like he could get
up in front of from early on get up in
front of a big crowd and kill it a level
that was considering headlining the way
I learned what it sounds like what
killing sounded like he was doing so you
know he was on his way out and I was
saying I'll do you wait till you go out
that's gonna be [ __ ] amazing tonight
he asked him I was like you want me to
take a picture or I don't know if I
asked him what up so he was walking out
and I wanted to take a picture of Chris
right when he got to the microphone
because the lights were up and you could
see how big the crowd was and I thought
it'd be a cool thing for him to have and
retweet or whatever and I was just
focused on Chris all right and Brody ins
had done the [ __ ] intro and I didn't
realize he was in frame one because I
was just looking at Chris to try and
frame it and I like liked the picture
and I was unaware that Stephen did this
you know with his baseball background
here's a pitch
and I forget we pitched Arizona or
Arizona State I think was Arizona State
I'm not sure and he you know you know
that warm-up that pitchers do like
whenever you see like spring training
before the game where they're walking
and they put their hand out like
straight out in front of them and like
above their head and then they just
kicked their leg up with their toe their
cleat of their toe touches their hand
I guess he used to do that I that was
the first time I ever saw him do it and
when I clicked the photo he was walking
offstage doing that and he had literally
kicked is what was at the apex almost
touching his hand with his his head
tucked down a little bit and I it just I
saw that and I just started just it was
just so him I just started [ __ ]
laughing and I'm just as a comedian like
why did he do that was was that for the
crowd was that for him what was the
person in the crowd as they're watching
Chris D'Elia walking on stage and then
in the peripheral they just see this guy
walking off kicking his he it's foot up
through his hand like a spring training
[ __ ] pitcher and them in the
Grapefruit League and for the rest of
that [ __ ] tour you know when you know
you get lonely on the road I would just
look at that picture and I would just
die laughing and so many people that I
showed who weren't in stand-up didn't
understand why that they would just sort
of like wow that guy can kick his foot
up a high or whatever they didn't get it
or it wasn't hitting him the way it was
hitting me but I just I don't know man I
don't know what else to say I just I
just it's just it's really obviously
really sad but I he just was I don't
know the way that guy touched me by what
he did I have this weird sort of I don't
know I can't yeah definitely I'm really
really sad but it's not that same kind
of sadness I'm not the most spiritual
guy but if there's if there's anything
he's there you know after this cuz I
don't know I I never heard anybody say
one bad [ __ ] word about that guy
who's always such a knight and he's
[ __ ] hilarious and all that so
anyways there goes another one so
um I don't know I guess I don't know he
would get frustrated I mean the whole
[ __ ] his whole thing is just like his
whole life was like an oscar-winning
movie as far as the way he battled like
what he battled and how positive he
stayed and like I always wondered like
what that what it was like for him to
have all like the best comics being like
dude you're like one of the funniest
guys ever and then not getting that from
the mainstream you know Wow you know
battling all that other [ __ ] I mean and
and and to not turn bitter and not be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's unbelievable it
really is so I guess now that like his
life is complete like kind of looking
back on it it was like it was weird like
he was on his what's that Grateful Dead
song it reminded me of that you know
that love that song ripple the way they
say what the [ __ ] how does that lyric go
let me look this up here it says there
there's a road no simple highway between
the dawn and the darkened night and if
you go no one may follow that path is
meant for your steps alone yeah I feel
like if they ever do like a documentary
which I'm sure they're going to like
that should be that should be the tone
because I don't know I don't know if I'm
saying this right but like I don't know
what that guy did was just so [ __ ]
unique in this there's a loneliness to
be in that [ __ ] unique and the fact
like I said that he didn't turn into a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about it and was just so
nice and supportive to everybody you
know I don't know I I don't measure up
to that put it that way so thank you to
Brody Stevens and all of the Steven
Brody Stevens all those [ __ ] times
you made me laugh and everybody else and
I don't know I think for the rest
my life I'm gonna be going to yes you
got it it just feels good to say it I I
mean half of my conversations I think I
had with him sadly enough was just me
imitating him he was so fun I would just
start talking talking like him so
anyways that's my two cents and there's
a bunch of clips of them if this made
you interested definitely look them up
and alright I guess I don't know what
the [ __ ] do you go from there
Jesus Christ dude like it's just what
being old is now I mean it's just
[ __ ] every like the comics die more
than other people cuz I you know I have
a whole list of everybody that died cuz
I don't want to forget them and I'm up
to like [ __ ] 32 comedians you know all
guys to every single one of them tell
you for all the bitching the women are
doing it stand up at least you're still
alive you can still do sets I was
actually talking to DeRosa and we were
just we were telling Stephen Brody
Stephens [ __ ] stories it's the
weirdest thing like on this cuz all
these people that have died there's
always been like a sadness and blah blah
blah and with everybody I've talked to
about Brody it's like you end up crying
laughing telling stories rather than
crying crying you know and we were
trying to remember here's another guy
you should look up as far as like just
[ __ ] hilarious who died is a comic
Rasheed Thurmond th you are mo ND and he
died right when I went to LA and I
remember a young guy - like 36 37 years
old
it was another another great one so
anyways where the [ __ ] do you go from
there
I've been running my set here in New
York City New York City one of the most
caring comedy crowds you're going to be
in front of Jesus Christ
I swear I feel like a three-year comic
when I perform in New York City now I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
part of its me because of this the
overly sensitive [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
that's going on it's forcing me to go in
the other direction you know to just
it's just it's tough you know it's the
balance of the universe it's like if if
you're gonna [ __ ] try to push me in
this this direction I'm gonna [ __ ] go
in the other one like if you back off
then I'm not gonna be as much of an
[ __ ] on stage but if you're gonna be
[ __ ] sitting there get in my grille
every time I [ __ ] say something it's
good it makes you make sure go hopefully
even further in the other direction
because comics were telling me they're
going on stage out here and other
comedians in front of just a regular
crowd it's not a benefit like again if
you're doing a cancer benefit they go
hey just don't do any cancer jokes I get
that but it's just a comedy show and
they go and don't talk about this don't
talk about that don't these [ __ ]
these people are going to undo
everything that Lennie Carlin and Pryor
these guys went to jail they went to
jail so you know began because they did
that believe it or not a lot of these
female comics that are on stage now
talking about their [ __ ] vaginas for
45 minutes you wouldn't be able to do
that if it wasn't for them and now it's
becoming this [ __ ] thing where I
don't I don't know I don't I really just
am baffled and every time I think like
okay we're gonna come out of this
ridiculously childish time and stand up
where where everybody is acting like
comedians of all the sudden presenting
legislation that is going to be turned
into law rather than it's just up there
somebody just just being an idiot
I don't know I was doing this some
[ __ ] Club I'm not going to say the
club I was doing the club and like I was
making fun of white women how they act
like they were oppressed you know I mean
when they're really
sitting in the jacuzzi with me you know
how they get the sidestep their white
privilege because they weren't allowed
to vote 90 years ago you know so I've
just got the right to vote 90 years ago
or whatever the [ __ ] hundred years ago
you know obviously just being a dick and
this white woman in the crowd just goes
I just guys just like that right and I'm
like that that's all you got
she's like what I had to say it like
she's literally patting herself on the
back for how brave she wasn't was
[ __ ] hilarious was just like the
complete lack of passion in fire the way
she protested what I said just it just
really shows like how unaffected you are
but by by whatever the [ __ ] it is you're
complaining about you know what I mean
truly oppressed people when they heck
when you say you cross a line when they
[ __ ] heckle you you feel like I'll
[ __ ] I went too far it isn't you don't
sigh like I was saying she sound like
she was down the bottom of a well so
anyways I don't know I was not bringing
these Stephen Brody Stephens positive
vibes to that show I was being a bit of
a dick so whatever I'll take I always
take my 50% of it you know so anyways I
go on to London today
let's look up we're all freckles is
gonna be I don't even know I think I
started Liverpool which I'm very excited
about she loves you yeah yeah Liverpool
right that's where the for [ __ ] mop
headache concert from the Beatles let's
see here let's go to my website bill
burr calm everybody if you're falling
along in your program bill burr calm I'm
going to be yes I'll be at Liverpool Oh
would you look at that
not until the 26 so I actually get an
extra day here I fly today today's 24th
by the time I land will be the 25th that
gives me a chance to [ __ ] chill out
I'm there for two days
rumor has it most salads coming to the
show kidding I really fell out following
the [ __ ]
soccer I tried I [ __ ] tried jim
breuer has the funniest [ __ ] bit
about americans trying to get into
soccer go once every four years should
try to get into it you buy the jersey
and he just starts imitating them
flopping all over the place but I will
say this I do really really enjoy the
sport now and I do see the beauty and
the skill and all of that [ __ ] now like
you know I'm not 100 percent the stupid
yank make in front of the world's most
popular sport and it isn't all faking
because I saw Moe salla a couple times
on a breakaway that's what they call it
in hockey I don't know what the [ __ ]
they call it and in your football over
there but like he's you know in the
clear and this guy just runs up behind
him and just sticks his leg out and
dragged his cleat down the back of his
[ __ ] calf but what was funny because
he was on the breakaway most shook it up
and then kicked the in you know kicked
it in the net but if he was anywhere
else he would have collapsed on the
field like he got shot although you know
having said all that I would not want
somebody do that to me so it's not all
it's not all faking so I'm in Liverpool
in the 26th and the 27th 28th I'm in
Glasgow and then the 29th I'm off and
then the first in second I'm in
Birmingham and then Manchester legendary
Manchester and then we go and then I
have two days off what the [ __ ] then I
got two days off and then I die
I'm at Royal Albert Hall on the fourth
and fifth taping my next stand-up
special and you know what I was watching
all these clips on Stephen Brody
Stephens and I came across I went to his
Instagram and all of that stuff and I
was watching I don't know somehow I
ended up coming across this quote that
Zach Galifianakis had that I'm really
going to take to heart because I've been
just working my [ __ ] ass off and it
was basically saying you know
don't feel like you have to be you know
working all the [ __ ] time
I can't paraphrase he said it perfectly
of course but I kind of took it to heart
like you know what what if I just
[ __ ] chilled out for a couple of
weeks I got that German Irish thing
where you just go until one day you
[ __ ] like oh what's that pain in my
chest and then you just fall forward
into your [ __ ] mushy peas and then
that's it so I'm going to try to I'm
gonna try to be around for a few I mean
I don't know how long I can do it
because there is a part of me that goes
[ __ ] nuts after four days of not
doing stand-up but I think I'm gonna go
a little bit easy here over the next
couple months and rather than just run
out because what I usually do is I
mediately I'll take like two days off
after I do a special then I really
mmediately get right back to the club
and I try to get it going again
and I think this time what I'm gonna do
is actually take a little bit of time
off from doing stand-up and rather than
just trying to force a new hour I'll go
live a life that sort of writes the next
hour hopefully hopefully that'll happen
now watch you guys later on this year
you know right after my special comes on
it just saw him it's like half the same
jokes [ __ ] freckled [ __ ] sucks all
right so there's 23 minutes I don't have
the advertising reads yet so I'm gonna
finish this one tomorrow when I'm
overseas once again I'm absolutely
heartbroken that's such a special person
like Steven is no longer with us but I
am like so inspired by the life that he
lived and so happy to have known him
only a little bit as little as I knew
him and that I actually got to see him
and I don't know man it's I don't know
it's the weirdest feeling I've ever had
after somebody I'd known that's died
where it's just like he just that
there's even a happiness I have
just I mean you know it was I think cuz
I just looked at his life and saw the
effect that he had on people you know
and he just kind of think like yeah man
he got it he got it you know he was a
yeah just a unbelievably positive
positive force and the lesson I learned
when Patrice died is that you know you
don't own these people they're just
gifts that you get and you don't get to
decide when they go and that's sort of
the cruel thing that you continue to
learn but I don't know looking at his
body of work you know I know personally
I'm gonna try to be a little bit less of
a Content try to live up to the high
standard that that he set alright okay
with that I'll read some advertising
here from London and with the magic of
editing this will only be a half a
second delay okay through the magic of
editing I am now in Liverpool England
that only took half a second through the
wonderful world of editing Jesus Christ
Oh God so I'm in Liverpool now the
driver was going you know he can go see
where the Beatles [ __ ] did all their
first shows which I really think that's
got to be like the cheers of Liverpool
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna walk in there yep right
over there right over there with where
they're not right now that's where they
were I don't know I'm just I don't have
a show tonight so I'm just sitting here
trying to figure out the goddamn heating
system here which I can't figure out I
don't know how to turn it on it pressed
every [ __ ] button and you know I
brought a [ __ ] adapter and whenever I
bring a mixer I always blow out my
[ __ ] mixer and lo and behold I
plugged it in before I plugged it into
the mixer and I just heard that the plug
just goes like the you know is just like
well I just fried that [ __ ] thing
even with the [ __ ] adapter I don't
know how it happens
it didn't fry
computer but my computer has three
prongs the mixer only has two is that
what the problem is somewhere in there
was it not grounded was there too much
of a surge any electricians that can
help me out I have no [ __ ] idea but
anyways let's continue let me read a
little advertising here stamps.com
no one really has time to go to the post
office it sounds like a fat person
making excuses why they can't go to the
gym you're busy who's got time for all
that traffic parking lugging all your
mail and packages it's a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the post office right to
your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices Jesus Christ on
an online seller shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
why is that [ __ ] thing doing that
simply I simply use your computer it's
simple what steps I come you get five
with a [ __ ] simply use your computer
to print us official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
any way you want to send once your mail
is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it's
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents after every first class stamp
and up to 40% off Priority Mail right
now my / our listeners get us oh I guess
I'm supposed to say my cousin by myself
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in BRR that's
stamps.com enter BRR
alright that's
all right let's talk about some [ __ ]
here all right so I did some more sets
in in New York had great sets Thursday
night and then Friday and Saturday I had
like those sort of typical New York sets
were you know I don't know it's just the
I don't know what I don't get it I don't
get him I was up there making fun of
women and then this woman in the crowd
white woman of course just goes right so
I just started making fun of her and she
just goes what I had to do it you know
like what she did was unbelievable and
brave and all of that type of [ __ ] and
it's just like you know I don't know if
you just heard it's just like these
[ __ ] white women were acting like
they were oppressed it's like you're
white okay that's my joke that's like
you're in the end of Jacuzzi with me
stop this stop it there's [ __ ]
whining all the [ __ ] time like like
you're really this oppressed minority
you know is you could tell how oppressed
she was by the level of passion she had
when she was yelling she's like hey [ __ ]
you had like no passion no fire no pain
whatever oh I don't know and all its
doing it just caused me to say more
ignorant [ __ ] that I wouldn't be saying
if they weren't [ __ ] act in that way
so just heads it's just a really weird I
know somebody actually wrote me a letter
and talked about the Caroline show which
I mean I had a good time but by no means
was it a smooth show said hey Oh Billy
thanks for coming out and putting on a
great show at Caroline's you were
absolutely hilarious I listened to your
podcast and after agree with you the
crowd wasn't typical New York I'm born
and raised New Yorker and noticed a ton
of what I'm sure we're hipster
transplant I don't I think they're just
younger people now and I just think it's
a product of being on social media and
seeing everybody getting in trouble
maybe that's what it is
because what any times I was doing a
show and this guy was like laughing but
he wouldn't look at me and he was almost
like
looking down and then looking across at
his friend like like he wanted to laugh
but he was afraid to I don't know it's
strange then he goes a couple of people
even kept looking over at me for
laughing so much just want you to know
that US natives and longtime New Yorkers
really appreciated and thoroughly
enjoyed your show I hope you weren't too
put off because I look forward to seeing
you perform here again so no yeah I mean
I'm not gonna [ __ ] quit coming to New
York
I just I'm having a difficult time
trying to figure out what exactly it is
that I'm feeling a three-year comic when
I go to New York I don't know but it is
what it is you know it's dictated by the
young not the old so they are setting
the tone and I guess I have to figure
out how to adjust to it
oh and old Robert Kraft Robert Kraft
getting all this [ __ ] for I don't know
what you know the man simply was trying
to buy his strip mall and he just went
over there and he was checking out some
of the stores what is the problem I
think it's such [ __ ] bull that's just
because he's famous I was talking to
this cop he goes anytime we bust a
rub-and-tug he goes you're trying to get
the people that run it you don't get the
John's you just scare them and you let
him go but all the sudden he's a famous
guy so now it's just like this big deal
you know and everybody's just like why
if you rob it crap do you need to go to
a rub-and-tug
and I would say that's because that's
how annoying it is to have a woman in
your life
[Laughter]
you can just get what you want without
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] moaning and
complaining well I don't know why he
went if he did I mean it's all [ __ ] a
legend anyways you know it did happen to
Florida so I mean we've been beating up
on the dolphins for so long I'm sure
that's why they didn't [ __ ] let him
go but it's great that it happens
because it gives people you know who
hate Boston because they've won all
these [ __ ] championships my favorite
thing is when I talk about all the
championships that they've won and like
people bring up like the Eagles or the
Giants that it's just like dude they
went six and three
you're not gonna win all of them I will
take those three losses all day long to
win six Super Bowls all [ __ ] day long
oh they'll I'll take the 86 year [ __ ]
curse of the babe to come back down
three games to none and into what
they've been doing I mean it's like it's
yet it's the pain that makes it great
so anyways anyway to say it properly let
me read a few more of these this podcast
might be a little bit short cuz I'm
beyond jet-lagged and thank God I don't
have a show tonight but now I'm like
wide awake cuz I came here and I
couldn't sleep on the plane I watched
two movies that I really enjoyed
I watched white boy Rick I got to give a
shout-out to that I mean Matthew
McConaughey is always great he's always
great but the two people that played his
kids white boy Rick movie let's see here
I just thought the acting was was superb
in that movie really really good movie
and then I also saw I'll figure out
there's IMDB I also saw the Freddie
Mercury movie Bohemian Rhapsody all
right
Ritchie Merritt [ __ ] killed it and
then Belle Polly both of them will [ __ ]
an amazing really good movie I'm not but
these are also airplane reviews but I
still think it was you know whenever
you're in a terrible Judah Friedlander
used to always say that when you run a
movie every [ __ ] movie is good but
these were actually really good movies
and then I also saw yet that Bohemian
Rhapsody Bohemian Rhapsody and he always
the funniest part of that movie for me
when I saw the original reviews of
Bohemian Rhapsody it's how I feel about
that song today I don't know if it's
just overplayed but that song drives me
up the wall I see
little silhouetto of a man no no no hope
to have never mama be a mama [ __ ] is
like oh my god I get it you could sing
Jesus Christ about a [ __ ] through-line
of a thought here but I really liked I
liked that movie but um and I was I was
in the air and missed all the all the
Oscar stuff but you know I thought it
was hilarious that Spike Lee was upset
it's just funny to me when adults get
mad that they don't win a [ __ ] trophy
you know it's just like what why do you
give a [ __ ] didn't you see how they
treated Martin Scorsese how long did he
have to wait before he [ __ ] before he
did [ __ ] uh before he finally got Best
Director when they finally gave it for
him there wasn't it wasn't even his best
one it should have been for the other
ones it's like that's what's gonna
happen to you you know they [ __ ] Denzel
on hurricane and then give him for them
for that [ __ ] King Kong hey God not
that on me they were always like a movie
or too late you know I don't I don't
know why I don't know why why would you
waste your time getting that [ __ ] I
don't know upset I did like that he was
dressed like Prince's grandfather though
[Laughter]
anyways anyway
I and most of those other movies I
didn't see I didn't say so I don't know
what are you going to do
all right the next thing I got here
somebody of course giving me [ __ ] for
saying I felt bad for Jesse's mullet I
just felt bad as far as like oh my god
he's got to feel like the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever and this guy of course gets
all passionate about it because why
would you get passionate about the
corporation's
that dictate our foreign policy and have
literally bankrupted this country when
you can get mad at an actor that got
100% busted for what he did and nobody
got hurt other than him he totally
destroyed his great say do you feel
sorry for him you hope who's kabiri buzz
the guy who was willing to let two
innocent people rot in jail I don't
think he thought he'd they were gonna
get caught considering he was acting
like it was two white people I think
what was supposed to happen was they
were supposed to sort of semi beat him
up he was supposed to blame it on [ __ ]
rott white people and like the two guys
who did is that were you saying the guy
was trying to cause even more racial
division and anger in this country
he didn't increase it or decrease it it
wouldn't have it just would have just
been another [ __ ] story that lasted
for three days it is where it is and
will remain that way and two people grow
the [ __ ] up
the guy who terrorized his co-workers by
sending fake hate mail with mysterious
white power powder in it to his place of
work pull your head out of your ass burr
alright maybe I was wrong about that I
thought it'd be it more of a unique take
other than to say you just said what
everybody else said congratulations sir
you know I still feel sorry for is you
who does not have an original [ __ ] I
think what everybody else thinks
oh that's entertaining I mean if I just
did that I could just be that big-headed
[ __ ] lady who's that lady who does
that show and she turns her head to the
side like Jim Rome you know she gets all
mad about cases about people who you've
been just horrific things have happened
to them but if horrific things didn't
happen to them then she wouldn't have a
mansion so the host shows kind of a
weird thing to watch yeah I might as
well be her
she looks like the the the cousin of
that woman who had the slave themed
wedding who used to do the cooking show
on the [ __ ] Food Network whatever her
[ __ ] name is Jesus you guys think I'm
in a bad mood watch that person show
always with the scowl on their face she
looks like that [ __ ] monster and uh
the [ __ ] is that the Bugs Bunny
you know monsters have such interesting
life so whatever used to say when Bugs
Bunny was doing is the things here that
no armed [ __ ] monster right anyways
sorry this is all jet lag [ __ ]
horseshit the [ __ ] am I talking about
here yeah anytime I see somebody just
completely [ __ ] their life up on some
level human being the human being I did
I just feel bad like a guy what did you
do you know I don't condone it and think
they should and I definitely think they
should be punished I don't know why I
always look at that like look at that
[ __ ] Bernie Madoff guy I just can't
imagine just I guess I'm looking at it
like the person actually has empathy for
other people maybe they don't I'm
putting myself into that situation where
I would be going like God every day
everybody's smiling you're the greatest
bill thanks for making me all this money
and I gonna be like thank you not to say
that I haven't been a piece of [ __ ] in
my life well maybe that's one of this
cuz I've been a piece of [ __ ] so I don't
excuse me for [ __ ] feeling bad for an
actor who made it and then [ __ ] the
whole thing up that has got to be the
most bizarre way ever to try and get a
raise but I still don't think that
that's why he was doing it I think he
had like some sort of victim fantasy or
something like that I think was more
that I don't think that that's how you
get a raise and I don't see if he really
thinks that that's the way it was the
was a way to get a raise like there was
the whole [ __ ] thing was so crazy
I feel like there's something about him
that he's not all there and now you just
making fun of somebody that has some
sort of mental issue I don't know or
he's like the world's dumbest criminal
maybe that's what it is I don't know but
you know what sir I
try to pull my head out of my ass and in
and have your thoughts which is what
everybody else thinks and that'll be an
entertaining podcast welcome to what
everybody else thinks
I'm your host bill burr the new Green
Deal sir did you get this mad that the
first mammal went extinct due to a
human-induced global warming did you
have that level of passion for it all
right the new Green Deal yo Billy planet
puss I'm into saving the environment and
I've been abstaining from plastic bags
and straws and buying the new iPhone
every year for most of my life but I'm
starting to question the narrative of
certain things okay you talked about aoc
I don't know what that is
the young congresswoman with big
ambitions wasn't sure if you heard this
but in the New York Green Deal she's
pushing there was a line-item supporting
those who were not able to work and
those who are not willing granted this
isn't likely to happen I think it's
insane to suggest that someone should
get a check for sitting around on their
ass my question is if the US government
decided to do this in civil war was
pending would you leave the country or
refuse to pay taxes Jesus Christ adept
at you and [ __ ] vertical on that last
line if the US government decided to do
it what the [ __ ] what could I do about
it I mean I guess I would essentially
work for free I don't know but it's
what's killing me is is we we have the
money to not with all the money that we
pay in taxes if we would get out of
these [ __ ] wars which are going
nowhere and have just bankrupted us and
made a very few amount of people in this
country super [ __ ] rich you wouldn't
have to then tin like this person
now coming along and going after people
then she's not she's not going to be
able to get all of those super rich
people do not have their money in this
country I saw this fascinating thing I
talked about this before how they they
they get it out of the country you know
their corporations set up a phony
corporation and one of these [ __ ]
islands and all the money goes there and
then they're an employee of that
corporation and then they set up another
corporation in a different Ireland
different company and then that debt
corporation builds the first one and
then there's another one in another
country and that one bills this one and
they just keep moving all of the money
throughout these islands all these the
Kia's is it's different countries so
with each country the IRS I guess the
amount of red tape they have to go
through and at each stop the corporation
Airport corporation pays off somebody
locally so it does cost them money to do
that but not nearly as much as what they
would pay in the United States and then
when I get to like the seventh or eighth
[ __ ] place that corporation then
gives the person in the United States
who doesn't want to pay taxes gives them
a loan gives them the money back in the
form of a loan which isn't taxable and
then they just never pay it back and
then the corporation quote forgives the
loan so the taxes that that person paid
was paying off people in each one of
those countries before it came back
which is very sophisticated and I don't
know that's how they [ __ ] do it now
this woman is not going to get those
people what she's gonna do is get like I
said stand-up comedians that are
suddenly selling tickets she's got to
get kids out of college that you know
created movement watches or started an
app she's going to basically be going
after and taxing the [ __ ] out of what
makes this country great the fact that
you can come from nothing and you can
get to that the absolute Heights you
know depending on how hard you work your
idea and your luck anyone can make it
she's going to be going after that and
completely ignore
ringg these corporations that have
bankrupted this [ __ ] country polluted
the [ __ ] drinking water turned up our
our food supply into poison have made
money millions and billions of dollars
in pharmaceutical the pharmaceutical
industry and in in with all these people
overdosing and all these families that
are ripped apart then Jenny she's not
gonna go after any of those [ __ ]
people she's just gonna get someone like
me who's just a [ __ ] individual
that's it you saw what happened when
Trump tried to pull the troops out of
Syria
you saw how both [ __ ] Democrats and
Republicans oh they were that's where
their bread is buttered by keeping those
corporations making all that money on
that [ __ ] war on those [ __ ] wars
and then when they're done they then get
to go around and give speeches and
that's how they wash their [ __ ] bribe
money and you watch this woman for all
these big ideas she has she's gonna come
out the other side she's gonna be a
Multi multi Multi multi [ __ ]
millionaire she's gonna have a [ __ ]
book deal she's gonna be on TV she's
gonna go on the talk show circuit and
everybody's gonna just sit there and
talk about what a [ __ ] inspiration
she is and you know it's it's just it's
all [ __ ] and then meanwhile you know
anybody who [ __ ] when I had the balls
to go after a dream and sleep on a futon
till they were like 38 and started
making some money is gonna be paying 70
percent taxes I guess that that's that's
the solution to it I don't know it
doesn't seem like you know I know a lot
of [ __ ] people that if you just gave
him a check every month would just sit
on their [ __ ] ass and play video
games
just because this changing technology
you have to [ __ ] join it learn how to
[ __ ] fix a robot's ACL or some [ __ ]
you know what I mean it's like I'm sure
there's a bunch of mechanics out there
right now if you're smart you start to
learn how to fix a an electric vehicle
rather than sticking with gas combustion
engines kind of trying to keep yourself
ahead of the [ __ ] game that's what
you have to do you got to [ __ ] it
just right I don't think the solution is
to turn around
you know if I was running [ __ ] too
take more than 50 percent income tax off
of anybody regardless of where the how
much money they're making should be
[ __ ] criminal there's no way the
person who did the job should make less
money than the person taxing you I don't
know that's just my my [ __ ] opinion
what the hell do I know I mentioned some
what tell me I need to take my head out
of my ass but I would imagine if we you
know converted to [ __ ] solar power
and in electric cars and all of that we
would take a massive massive bite out of
the Middle East and all of those people
that fund these [ __ ] terrorist groups
and to things they wouldn't have the
money to be any sort of a threat to us
we wouldn't be [ __ ] over there and
eventually they would just go back to
fighting each other the same way they
[ __ ] did in Eastern Europe when
Russia pulled out they went right back
to picking up their fights they were
like where were we and they went right
back to [ __ ] killing each other so I
don't know I know I'm oversimplifying
all of this [ __ ] but I would think
because we're their biggest customer
that if we pulled out of there that
would massively hurt any sort of
terrorist groups ability to try and go
after us you know I don't know the [ __ ]
do I know why do you guys to ask me such
deep questions you know I don't [ __ ]
read the paper right a long time
ozzie lady listener g'day bill long time
listener here from Melbourne Australia
who would love to hear you your take on
my situation all right
well did you really have to listen my
bad Aussie Aussie accent er I'm in the
second half of my 20s out here we call
that your late 20s I work in a TV job I
love I'm independent have great friends
and enough hobbies slash personal
interest to keep me busy and entertained
in everyday life I've been told I'm a
catch but it ain't all rainbows and
sunshine not only am i single but by my
cynicism by my cynicism has become so
powerful that it's compromising my
ability to date or trust I think we want
to say but my cynicism a bit of a
background here years ago I was in a
long-term relationship with ended in
heart
for me and since then I've been through
a sequence of disappointing dating
experiences which has left me more
lonely and unlovable each time people
have named me good luck Chuck because
whenever I get involved with anybody
they settle down with the next person
they come across I fear him becoming an
angry person men seem to think I'm more
of a good time than a long that a long
time or a good answer for boredom
I also need seem to attract men in
relationships or worse married but how
can I become less of a cynic the reality
is that some people just don't end up
finding someone well not with that
attitude
they go through life falling in love
alone or not at all
my mother has has been single for 10
years and doesn't intend on changing
that do you think some people are meant
to be alone was there ever a point in
your life where you thought you'd end up
alone cheers and go [ __ ] yourself
absolutely I did and I went through the
same [ __ ] that you're going through yeah
and I had you know women I dated and
then I [ __ ] it up and then they would
go on the next guy they'd marry him yeah
had that happen a couple of times and
then I dated you know and thought went
for a while I thought women were psychos
and then I just realized that what I was
doing was I kept going after roughly the
same kind of person I kept fishing in
the same poison pond if you will I think
you just need to get a little therapy
and become a little more positive and
obviously if somebody's married or in a
relationship you shouldn't you know I
think that should be one of your first
[ __ ] questions and there has to be
something that you're doing and I'm
saying this as as as a way as a positive
thing that if that's what you're
attracting there has to be something
that you're doing he did that that can
only happen so many times before you got
to be figuring out what the [ __ ] am i
doing
that's what I did with psycho women when
I was just like you know looking chick
to psychos and then after a while once
you date like the third fourth fifth one
in a row you like alright what am i
doing
oh I'm deliberately going after these
people because I'm afraid to commit and
then when they break up with me there's
no [ __ ] heartache because there are
their [ __ ] mind so I think some
people were meant to be alone but it
doesn't sound like you are if you were
meant to be alone you would be way more
okay with it than you are and this
doesn't just seem like you're looking at
the herd and it's making you question
yourself you sound like you want to find
love so what I would do is take some of
your TV money and I would get a good
therapist and I would do some work on
yourself and start fishing in a
different pond how about that
did I oversimplify what was going on I
probably did anyways anyway I'm still
keep saying anyways I think it's one of
one of my charms that I don't I don't
have command of my own language all
right that is the that is the podcast
geez we got [ __ ] deep on this one huh
passing of Stephen Brody Stephens my how
to solve the [ __ ] Middle East problem
the audacity to be doing that and I
don't know what else
look at this Keith Robinson just texted
me he's like haha looks like Robert
Kraft won't be going to the White House
this year oh yeah I guess I'll go cry
with his six [ __ ] trophies not to
mention I you know I don't is it I don't
know I've never had this experience
before that my team's the team that wins
everything it was it always this [ __ ]
petty that's all they do is just come up
with petty [ __ ] I guess he won't be
[ __ ] good dance that's like okay yeah
I guess we'll just have to [ __ ] cry
on my trophies and move on they're not
taking the team away who gives a [ __ ]
and not only that it's [ __ ] it's
Donald Trump
he was probably he was probably the
driver in the getaway car from the
rub-and-tug did you grab them by the
pussy's
anyways alright anyway that is the that
is the podcast congratulations to
everybody out there that won the shiny
things my condolences for the
who didn't I hope people who watch
movies and we're offended by them could
somehow move past it and find a reason
to get up in the morning tomorrow people
it's a [ __ ] award show I mean they're
don't don't they [ __ ] it up in your
business to topsails bed and everybody's
sitting this [ __ ] goddamn brown noser
he's banging the [ __ ] boss's daughter
he's getting married to her that's why I
[ __ ] want it you know they're always
that [ __ ] there's always gonna be that
[ __ ] you know quit you [ __ ] crying
so what's what a [ __ ] great country
this is you know it's such a great
country people complain about the movies
I didn't like the way it made people
with red shirts look meanwhile this
[ __ ] polar bears [ __ ] drowning add
another flat screen to your [ __ ] TV
so your [ __ ] TV room so you can
[ __ ] watch the Oscars and cry about
it
alright I'm off my [ __ ] soapbox here
we go I'm in the bubble everybody I am
in the bubble this time next week was
gonna be Monday I'm gonna be doing my
first taping and then the next day I'll
do my next taping and then that we will
be putting this hour in 30 minutes to
[ __ ] bed I can't wait I'm very
excited I miss my daughter and wife
terribly and I'm really gonna take it
easy this year I really am I'm talking
to my agent I'm gonna be the California
kid I'm doing gigs out the [ __ ] Cali
and I'm just gonna stay in the southwest
I'm gonna fluff I can't fly southwest of
the gig in under 50 minutes I'm not
[ __ ] doing it and I'm just gonna
[ __ ] chill I got an acting gig this
summer then I'm bringing my wife and kid
along too and I'm just gonna slip some
life and let this thing come together oh
my god my wife sent me this video my
kids sing in the ABCs and I do this
thing I don't know if I probably told
you this [ __ ] so [ __ ] jet lag but I do
this thing the way I sing
the ABCs I go ABCD efg hijk LMNOP hey
you know I'm bouncing up and down she
just laughs and all that stuff so now
she can do the ABCs and she throws the
haze in there she's like qos hey tuv hey
it's the cutest [ __ ] thing ever
and it's all that matters in life and
then you [ __ ] put on the TV and you
watch adults [ __ ] whining cuz they
didn't get this star in their forehead
who gives a [ __ ] you're making movies
you're a millionaire you're banging
beautiful women you know what the [ __ ]
else do you need
I wanted the shiny thing I'd like to
thank the Academy [ __ ] half the
people in the world trying just get a
[ __ ] sandwich boohoo I didn't get a
trophy I will never get I will never
[ __ ] understand that but then again I
do watch sports and I get excited that
my team went Stroh fees and I'm about
ready to [ __ ] trash Keith Robinson
and his sorry ass [ __ ] cowboys who
the Patriots just passed four more Super
Bowl titles we won more Super Bowl
titles where among us Adium we've won
more Super Bowl titles in the last two
decades than the Cowboys have won in
their entire [ __ ] history Tom Brady
has more rings than all the Dallas
Cowboy quarterbacks combined oh I'll do
I have some ammo and I have to take
advantage of it now because I know when
Tom leaves and Bill Belichick retires
you know I have faith in like the
[ __ ] but ancef wait Robert Kraft
right simply trying to buy a strip mall
and checking out the stores that [ __ ]
guy arguably the greatest owner of all
time when you look at his coaching arse
he's hired three coaches Bill Parcells
[ __ ] what's-his-name there whoa I
just totally forgot his [ __ ] name
Pete Carroll Bill Belichick three four
[ __ ] three Hall of Famers that's too
Super Bowl three Super Bowl nine Super
Bowls amongst all of them amazing all
right that's it that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves and I will talk to you
I'll check in on you in a couple of days
I don't know where I'm gonna be but I
got Liverpool the next couple of the
next couple of nights and very excited
to be here I've never been here and as
much as I was making fun of all that
Beatles [ __ ] I'm definitely gonna go
look at it you know I got I go I'm not
gonna go to the pub where they [ __ ]
start is of course I'm gonna go all
right and I'm gonna you know I know Mike
I don't think I'm gonna go all their
[ __ ] houses Roy this is where Ringo
was sleeping was it how the [ __ ] do I
know that all right I'll see you